foreign
[Music]
was just really like uh you're you're
preparing a cushy space to die you know
um you're just seeking creature comfort
in an environment where you're not
supposed to be comfortable because
essentially you've given up hope and you
know if we can get a chance to get a
hold of these guys when they come into
the system from the beginning then we
can ensure that they never even have to
go because yeah they rolls away at your
at your soul man it's Soul erosion and
and it changes you you know I remember
coming into the system and I had a
I was kind of thinking like you know
those uh the portals in the submarine
where you can block it off I said all
right I'm gonna put a partition and I'm
gonna put you know the essence of me
behind this everything else can be
sacrificial to this place because my mom
you know she uh she was telling me I'm
seeing that that twinkle in your eyes
starting to you know to them you know
and
and it made me think okay well maybe if
I just store this place that makes me me
off behind this portal and everything
else can be sacrificial and then next
thing you know you realize that that
portal has been breached and it's taking
more of you than you even anticipated to
give and and that's that's the nature of
of
you know dealing with something like
this you know
hopelessness is a is a very play a rough
place to be
you know so we get an opportunity to
rescue these dudes from from ever
filling that full brunt of that
experience you know and there's such a
strength in the community of it after
all there yeah I mean would you you know
with that mindset of uh I came here to
find a cushy place to die whatever that
is or people it's a it's a sentence
I mean you you were born here too in a
way would you say that
oh yeah that's a good way to look at it
you're absolutely right because I do I
do believe exactly what Alex said I do
believe that if it wasn't for this place
I wouldn't be here at all right you know
um can you walk me through that well
just because
I was I was Reckless I didn't even I
didn't even wreck I didn't even
recognize the recklessness that I had
normalized the way that I was living my
life was destructive and I didn't even
know it and I was gonna put myself in a
position where either somebody was going
to do me you know uh definitely harm or
or I would have done them and
coming here to this place and
and being in that in that hopelessness
it just it just I don't know man it's
just it's not just and not just that but
being told that you have nothing coming
because you're a no one
we're not going to waste your time on
you it just it messes up with your psych
too when you first come in not not
having anybody there for you
um yeah like you're disposable right
yeah you're disposable they're not even
willing to waste their time on you
because you have no potential of ever
getting home
so that was one of the one of the spots
we had to dig our way out you know not
just our bad relationships but just
everything else we had to work on our on
our own because nobody else was gonna do
it it was hard at the beginning of our
sentence we came in when it was a
different time than it is now
it was uh
it was real hard
you could see that you could feel the
tension in the air you everything was
everything was different back then
imagine coming into these walls and
seeing bully holes in the in the walls
what does that do to somebody has never
been to prison before
um
it really uh it really opens your eyes
to uh to prison how you're no longer
seen it like in a movie you're seeing it
in real life so you got two options
either you're gonna conform to what what
is going to be in here or you're not you
know and it's it's a it's a big step
and being able to navigate through that
and then eventually uh being able to
find that hope you know or that hope
again that uh they're not giving up that
Humanity that we somehow lost or got
disconnected with when uh we were doing
all the stuff we were doing in the
streets to feel that compassion for the
next man to put yourself in his spot
now I see the news I see different
things I see somebody heard and I feel
their pain you know it's I see them I
think what can I do to try to help this
person out and it's uh it's a different
me than somebody that I didn't care like
10 or 15 years ago or even 20. that's
why I said prison saved my life like May
was saying that it's out there
I'm in here for murder if I never got
arrested maybe either I would have kept
on killing or
or somebody would have killed me and
maybe my family would have got caught in
the crossfire so that's why I say prison
really saved my life it it opened me up
it helped me change it helped me
rehabilitate and I'm a better person for
it now people are so isolated
and you know so unbelievably uh
you know without Role Models without you
know that's just there's there's a
there's hopelessness everywhere and um
it's palpable you know the the the hope
that you guys spread to each other and
then around this institution
is there any way you can kind of um
describe the the effect that you think
that this group has on everyone else
here
well I think the Optics of it first you
know when you see those who have no hope
right being so positive right so it's
like well damn dang there's no benefit
for what they're doing you know surely
to be a live a better existence for sure
you have more peace of mind be
spiritually more sound right especially
in a um you know everything is uh
it's a it's a good thing everything's
become incentive based where you know if
you attend these programs
um by you signing your name on this line
every 52 hours you're gonna get x amount
of time off your sentence
um you know if you attend the college
courses like Alex said then you know you
get milestones and you get credits you
know none of that applies to us so to
see us sitting in those seats Faithfully
in those circles in them sacred settings
that says something you know what I mean
and then to his point when you when you
walk in the walk
this community is not um
is not sitting in those seats and taking
the knowledge and doing nothing with it
you know we're taking those you know
we're taking the knowledge in those
tools and we're bringing it to the yard
and we're applying it and I believe that
speaks volumes as well
um and then add to the fact that a lot
of us you know we're involved in a lot
of Destruction before we did start
walking a straight path so that
credibility is there when you're
speaking to someone who's not going to
respect you know somebody who's never
done what they're doing you know they
were actually striving to be like you
and then you telling them like nah man
that right there that version you
striving for that's not it and I also
believe that you know walking these
yards for years and individuals having a
chance to see the old the old version of
you
and see how enthusiastic you were down
that negative path and they see you
putting that same energy in that same
fire into the new version of you it
gives them hope and they're like damn
you know what let me go ahead and uh me
get on what he's on hey man uh Brad man
you think you can sign me up for one of
the classes that's so cool
[Music]